our next presenter has taken punches
from both Robert DeNiro and Macaulay
Culkin and says Culkin hits harder and
he won an Oscar for Goodfellas she is
the delightful young star and Oscar
winner earlier tonight please welcome
the stars of My Cousin Vinny Joe Pesci
and Marisa Rodham Torme
our category is makeup and the artists
who practice the art of artifice are
masters of their craft that's right with
some powder putty and prosthetics they
can make anyone look any way they want
they can even take older people and turn
them into use
did you say Utes here are this year's
nominees for makeup
thanks to these makeup artists V Neil
Ronnie Spector and Stan Winston that
rare bird Danny DeVito is transformed
into an even rarer bird the penguin in
Batman Returns greg cannom Michelle
Burke and Matthew W Mungle put their
heads together to create the many faces
and features of that no-account count
Bram Stoker's Dracula V Neil grey kanima
John Blake had a nose for what could
turn Jack the actor into Jimmy the
teamster in the movie Hoffa
is there anything you don't know and the
Oscar from goes to Greg Gannon Michael
Burke and Matthew Mungle Bram Stoker's
Dracula
Thank You Academy
thanks to my crew Mitch Devane Larry Oh
Dean Glenn Hahn Stuart Harding
sollentuna taro John Logan Rowland Todd
Steve Matt Mike Rob Helen Cohen Ron
singer
dr. Greenspan dr. silver especially want
to thank Chuck Mulvihill fred fuchs Gary
Martin and Columbia ACO Pat Churchill
Jim Hart Rick Baker who I started with
many years ago for everything dick Smith
John Chambers William Tuttle and the
other legends and thank you Gary Oldman
especially for your incredible
performance and patience and for this
and the opportunity Thank You Francis
Ford Coppola
thank you as a thespian I grandly
welcome this rare opportunity to be
myself to be or not to be
thank you my Hamlet has now been seen by
1 billion people oh sit down next year
Macbeth
as an actor people ask me are you always
on and the answer of course is no no a
thousand times no the nominees for sound
effects editing are Aladdin Marc Mangini
Bram Stoker's Dracula Tom C McCarthy and
David E stone under siege
John Levesque and Bruce Stemler and the
Oscar goes to I knew it Clint yo me 10
the Oscar goes to Tom C McCarthy and
David E stone for Bram Stoker's Dracula
I'm very honored to be here tonight like
to take this time to thank some people
who made this dream come true Francis
Ford Coppola fred fuchs Gareth Wiggins
the people the Sony Studios the Sony
Studios post effects and sound
Department our Foley Walker's mixers at
soul truth and to accrue that this
belongs to all of us thank you very much
I want to thank Francis Ford Coppola and
fred fuchs Chuck Mulvihill and gore so
and Nick Smith and Tom and I are here
representing an army of creative people
with more than 15 editors of dialogue
effects ADR and Foley and the Foley an
ADR at artists and mixers and thanks to
Leslie shots and his team of mixers and
designers special thanks to Steve Bourne
Dave cone to my wife Vanessa and my son
Nathaniel it's nap time
dusty Lindsey and Roxanne
you know it did this thing sound effects
editing I can't believe that NBC News
wasn't nominated for that you think you
turn so quickly